مع مرور سته اشهر على اطلاق الحكومه
العراقيه معركه استعاده الموصل من تنظيم
الدوله قالت منسقه الامم المتحده لشؤون
الانسانيه ان مئات الالاف من المدنيين
المحاصرين في البلده القديمه يواجهون اسوا
كارثه انسانيه يشدها الصراع في العراق
نتيجه انقطع الماء والغذاء عن
المحاصرين
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما الذي يؤخر حسم معركه الموصل بعد
مرور نحو نصف عام على اطلاقها وهل من
مبررات للثمن الانساني الضخم الذي دفع
فيها حتى
الان سته اشهر ونيف مرت على انطلاق معركه
استعاده الموصل من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
منذ البدايه لم يخطط لان تطول هذه المعركه
كل هذه الشهور وهذا ما دع كثيرين بعد مرور
شهر واحد فقط على بدئها للتساؤل عن اسباب
تاخر حسمها واذا جز التساؤل انذاك فمن باب
اولى ان نكرر سؤال الان بعد مرور نصف عام
دون استعاده المدينه وبعد دفع تكلفه بشريه
وانسانيه وماليه كبيره وسط تح دير الامم
المتحده من كارثه وشيكه قد تكون الاسوا في
عمر الصراع بين الحكومه العراقيه وتنظيم
الدوله تقرير زياد
بركات تدخل معارك الموصل مرحلتها الاسو
يتحول القتال الى حرب شوارع
حقيقيه في هذه الازقه والشوارع الضيقه
يدخل الجيش العراقي بمركبات وبها يقصف ذاك
ما كان الامريكيون انفسهم قد استبعد عدوه
مغلبين تحول الحرب الى راجله وبالتالي
التقدم بالامتار لا اكثر لذلك وفقا لمنسق
الامم المتحده للشؤون الانسانيه في العراق
اثمان باهظه وربما تكون غير مسبوقه في
تاريخ الحرب على تنظيم الدوله فتقدم الجيش
يحدث بين بيوت متلاصقه ووسط مئات الاف
المدنيين العالقين في الحي القديم من
الموصل والمناطق المجاوره ما يزيد من
احتمال تحول الامر الى كارثه هي الاسوا
على الاطلاق يعطف على هذا بحسب المسؤوله
الامميه ان ثمه شحا مهولا للماء والغذاء
في المناطق المحاصره اضافه الى مخاطر اخرى
تتمثل في القصف العشوائي والاستخدام
المفرط للطائرات من دون ال طيار وسعي
القياده السياسيه الى انجاز عسكري سريع
وباي الثمن ما يعني مجزره انسانيه تحرص
هذه القياده على ان يسمع بها احد ثمت ما
يشبه الاجماع على ان من تبقى من مسلحي
تنظيم الدوله لا يتجاوزون الالف مسلح في
اكثر التقديرات تساهلا وميلا للمبالغه
وهؤلاء كما يقول الجيش العراقي يتخذون
السكان دروعا بشريه ما يوجب تغييرا في
التكتيكات العسكريه لتقليل الخسائر في
صفوف المدنيين لكن ما يحدث على الارض وفقا
لمعارض الحمله العسكريه ان الجيش يخوضها
بلا استراتيجيات عسكريه واضحه ومتسخه فمره
يطالب المدنيون بالبقاء في منازلهم وحين
يفعلون يتعرضون لقصف يسوي بيوتهم بالارض
ومره اخرى يطلب منهم البحث عن ملاذات امنه
واذا استجابوا وجدوا انفسهم في مرمى نيران
الطرفين والارقام هنا تبدو مفزعه هناك نحو
نصف مليون نازح من الموصل ومثلهم او اقل
قليلا عالقون بين نيران القصف وكثير منهم
معرضون للموت قتلا او جوعا او في عمليات
انتقام يقول بعض السكان انها طائفيه وتهدف
الى تغيير التركيبه السكانيه للمدينه اذا
امكن ولا تحول مشاركه قوات امريكيه في
العمليات العسكريه دون تزايد الانتهاكات
التي يقوم بها مسلح الحشد الشعبي ويعتقد
عسكريا ان حسم معارك الموصل لا يعني هزيمه
تنظيم الدوله تلقائيا ويذهب الامريكيون
الى ان التنظيم يتقهقر في الموصل لكنه ما
زال موجودا في عده مناطق من من الانبار
اضافه الى انه يعيد بناء قدراته العسكريه
في ديالا وصلاح الدين ما يعني ان الموصل
جزء من الحرب وليست كلها وان هزيمته تتطلب
استراتيجيات واضحه وشامله بينما يضيف
اخرون ان تطييف الحرب على التنظيم يمنحه
وقودا اضافيا للبقاء واعاده بناء حاضنته
الشعبيه كلما تاكلت ذلك يعني ان تربح
معركتك ضده وتخسر في الوقت نفسه حربك
عل لمناقشه موضوع هذه الحلقه معنا من
واشنطن الادميرال ويليام فالون القائد
السابق للقياده الوسطى الامريكيه والاسطول
الخامس الامريكي ومن عمان الدكتور يحيى
الكبيسي مستشار المركز العراقي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه مرحبا بكما دكتور الكبيسي كل
مره يقال اقتربنا من الحسم المساله كلها
يعني مساله ايام واحيانا اسابيع ولكن الان
نحن
تجاوزنا السته اشهر نصف عام بالكامل لماذا
طالت المعركه كل هذا الامد
يعني يعني بدايه مساء الخير الك ولضيفك
الكريم من واشنطن ولمشاهده قناه الجزيره
يعني نحن هنا نتحدث عن معركتين مختلفتين
يعني معركه الساحل الايسر ومعركه الساحل
الايمن في معركه الساحل الايسر قلنا اكثر
من مره عبر الجزيره انه الخطه في بدايتها
بنيت على اساس اسس انه داعش لن يقاتل في
المدينه وانه سينسحب بمعنى يعني التجارب
التي خاضها الجيش العراقي في يعني المعارك
الاخيره تحديدا معارك الفلوجه وما بعد
الفلوجه عندما عمد التنظيم الى الانسحاب
بعد سقوط حا حائط الص الصد الاول يعني في
مدينه الفلوجه نتذكر عندما سقط حائط الصد
الاول في منطقه حي الشهداء عمد التنظيم
الى الانسحاب مباشره كان هناك اع قاد لد
لدى المخطط العراقي بانه قوات داعش لن
تقاتل كثيرا لهذا لم تكن هناك قوات كافيه
في معركه الساحل الايسر للسيطره على
المدينه في حال قرار داعش بالقتال
بالمدينه ولهذا فوجئت القوات العراقيه
بانه داعش قرر البقاء وقرر القتال لهذا
يعني وقعوا في في مشكله حقيقيه لهذا وجدنا
انه اضطرت القوات العراقيه في حينها الى
استدعاء قوات اضافيه الى تغيير قواعد
الاشتباك في المعركه الى اضافه يعني محاور
اخرى الى المعركه الى ان حسمت في معركه
الساحل الايمن كان الموضوع مختلف تماما
يعني كان هناك يعني رغبه بالحسم السريع
يعني بنيت خطه الساحل الايمن على اساس
الحسم السريع لهذا منح يعني القاطع الاخطر
والاهم المتعلق بالمدينه القديمه يعني
المحور الجنوبي الذي يصعد بامتداد يعني
نهر دجله الى قوات الشرطه الاتحاديه التي
لا تملك يعني خبرات في قتال المدن لانها
اعتمدت استراتيجيه
التدمير والقوه النيران المفرطه وليس
القتال
ولكنها انه داعش كانت متهيئ جدا لمه هذه
المركه دكتور يعني مهما كانت الفوارق
التكتيكيه وا الاستراتيجيه ولكن نحن نتحدث
عن معركه كحزم واحده هنا اسال الادميرال
فالون ان كنت تجد فعلا اسباب موضوعيه لهذا
التعثر لعدم الحسم الان في معركه
الموصل نعم اكبر عامل كما تعلمون الموصل
مدينه ذات كثافه سكانيه عاليه ومن الصعب
ان تتغلغل
داخل هذه المدينه وراينا انه كان منذ
البدايه صعبا جدا على القوات العراقيه
الدخول الى المدينه نظرا لتواجد اعداد
كبيره من المدنيين ونحن طبعا تعلمنا هذا
في اماكن اخرى في بغداد بعقوبه خلال
السنوات الماضيه نعم ايضا في الفلوجه من
الصعب ان تقاتل في هكذا مدن عندما يقرر
العدو الاستفاده من الكثافه السكانيه
والتحصن داخل وسط المدينه فهذا طبعا يقلل
من الخيارات ومن الصعب ان نستخدم الاسلحه
الثقيله في تلك المناطق هذا ليس شيئا
مفاجئا بالنسبه لي ان يستغرق الوقت فتره
طويله لتحرير الموصل نعم بالتاكيد ستكون
نهايه تنظيم الدوله قريبه ولكن يجب التمسك
بهذه المبادئ حتى انهاء العمل ام سيد
الكبيسي هل تعتقد ان هذه المعركه تخاض
باستراتيجيه
واضحه لا اعتقد ذلك الحقيقه يعني على
الاقل اذا اخذنا معركه الجانب الايمن على
سبيل المثال كان واضح انه الخطه فيها بعض
الاشكاليات يعني اولا كما قلت عندما تمنح
القاطع الاهم لقوات غير مهيئه لمعارك
شوارع ومعارك حرب مدن تقليديه هذه اشكاليه
اساسيه الامر الثاني انه عمليه حصار
المدينه يعني تضرر منه المدنيون وليس
تنظيم الدوله داعش بمعنى نحن نعرف جميعا
انه يعني عمليه حصار لمدينه بدات بعد
انطلاق العمليات العسكريه ومنح هذا يعني
هذا الواجب لقوات الفرقه التاسعه التي
تقدمت من المحور الغربي شمالا باتجاه
بادوش يعني يعني هذه الطريقه مكنت داعش من
الاستمرار الحصول على مساعدات وامدادات
الى اخر لحظه في حين منع من المدنيون من
ذلك لانه كان هناك حصار مطبق على المدنيين
طوال الفتره الماضيه نعم هناك اشكاليات
متعدده في قضيه المعركه وتخطيطها الاهم
هنا هو يعني غياب العنصر المحلي القادر
على معرفه هذه المدينه بشكل كامل يعني
هناك غياب شبه مطلق للعنصر المحلي داخل
الق القوات العسكريه العراقيه وبالتالي
هذا ايضا اذف عامل اضافي الى تعقيدات
المعركه نعم كثافه السكانيه الموجوده في
المدينه كانت عامل رئيسي في التاخر ولكن
نحن نتذكر ايضا انه هذه الكثافه السكانيه
لم تمنع في مناطق اخرى يعني لناخذ مثال
الفلوجه على سبيل المثال كان هناك بحدود
90,000 يعني مدني داخل مدينه الفلوجه لكن
قرار داعش بالانسحاب حسم المساله وبالتالي
نعم هناك تعقيدات فيما يتعلق ب يعني وجود
كثافه سكانيه هائله ولكن فقط اصحح لسيد
الادمرال انه لا الاسلحه الثقيله استخدمت
بكثافه يعني وهناك وثائق صوريه عديده تثبت
انه القوات العراقيه استخدمت كل الطاقه
الناريه الموجوده لديها وبالتالي لا يعني
القول انه لم تستخدم يعني اسلحه ثقيله في
هذه المعركه لا اعتقد انه دقيق ط طيب سيد
فلون يعني انت قلت انه طبيعي يعني
بالمواصفات الموجوده خاصه في مدينه ذات
كثافه سكانيه ان تطول المعركه الىى هذا
الحد ولكن هل لديك اي ملاحظات على
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه التي تخاض بها هذه
المعركه الى حد الان والتحالف التحالف
الغربي هو شريك تقريبا في هذه
العمليه
ليست لي دريه كافيه بالتفاصيل
ومختلف الامور العسكريه ولكن الهدف
الاساسي هو استعاده المدينه والشيء الاخر
هو القضاء على تنظيم الدوله اذا ما قرر
البقاء والاستمرار في الحرب نعم العمليه
العسكريه تتقدم
ببطء لا يمكن ان اقول بان هناك تجربه
سابقه في هكذا صراعات لان هذه المدينه
تشهد هذا الحدث لاول مره ونعم هناك محاوله
للتقدم وهناك استفاده من الغطاء الجوي
الذي توفره قوات التحالف للقوات العراقيه
وكما تعلمون من الصعب جدا ان تتقدم في
هكذا محيط وهكذا بيئه صعبه ووعر لانه من
الضروري ان ناخذ بعين الاعتبار المدنيين
المتواجدين في تلك الاماكن لذلك هناك تقدم
بطيء ومحاوله لانهاء هذا العمل وليس هناك
استعجال وايضا ذلك يهدف الى منع هروب
مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله اذا ما تم الانتهاء
من هذه العمليه فاعتقد ان تنظيم الدوله لن
يكون له فضاء يلجا اليه في العراق او فضاء
محصور جدا قد يلجا اليه في العراق من
الهام جدا ان نرى ما الذي تفكر به الحكومه
لمنح الثقه للناس بعد انتهاء من
تنظيف الموصل من مقاتل تنظيم الدوله وهذا
هو شي الاهم بالنسبه للمواطنين هناك في
الموصل دكتور كبيسي هل هذا صحيح هل توافق
على وجهه النظر هذا يعني ان حسم معركه
الموصل سيقضي نهائيا على تنظيم
الدوله لا انا اعتقد هناك مبالغه في هذا
هذه المساله يعني لنتذكر فقط انه من بقي
من مقاتلي داعش في مدينه الموصل عدد محدود
جدا يعني التقديرات تتحدث عن 1000 الى
2000 مقاتل وربما يعني هناك يعني بعض
التقديرات تتحدث عن ثلاثه الا مق مقاتل
ليس اكثر في حين نحن نعرف انه عدد
المقاتلين الذين كانوا في مدينه الموصل
يزيد عن ذلك كثيرا وبالتالي تنظيم الدوله
داعش يعني قرر في اللحظه الاخيره انه
الدفاع عن المدن والبقاء للقتال في في
المدن سهيه بشكل كامل لهذا هو اعتمد على
يعني الابقاء على قوات محدوده داخل المدن
والانسحاب الى يعني المناطق الواسعه التي
ما زال يسيطر عليها في صحراء الانبار في
صحراء نينو في مناطق اخرى يعني ما زال
تنظيم داعش يسيطر على مساحه لا لا تقل باي
حال من الاحوال عن 20% من الاراضي
العراقيه مناطق واسعه وديان جبال وهذه
كلها يعني يستطيع داعش استخدامها بسهوله
وليست هناك امكانيه للقوات العراقيه
لتعقبه في هذه المساحات الشاسعه والواسعه
ادميرال فالون انت كنت تستمع الى الى ضيفي
يعني تنظيم الدوله يعني ليس من الوارد ان
ينمحي بين ليله عشيه وضحاها بدليل انه
يعيد بناء نفسه الان في عده مناطق اذا
قضيه القضاء على التنظيم يبدو انها ستكون
تحدي اخر يعني غير حسب معركه
الموصل من الصعب جدا ان نستاصل تنظيم
الدوله
ومجموعات من هذا النوع هذا امر غير واقعي
ولكن
الشيء الواقعي والمعقول هو انه بالامكان
التقليل بشكل كبير من فعاليه هذا التنظيم
وهذه العمليه الجاريه الان وقيد تحقيق
المقاربه ليست فقط عسكريه انا متاكد ستكون
هناك عمليات عسكريه اخرى لتنظيف مناطق
اخرى من تواجد مقاتلي التنظيم الدوله
وحكومه العراق المركزيه تعمل جاهده
بالتعاون مع شركائها في التحالف الدولي
للقضاء على تنظيم الدوله
وستحاول اعاده بناء تلك مدن والحكومه
ستحاول ايضا اقناع الناس بان الحكومه ستمد
لهم يد العون والمساعده وهذا من شانه ان
يقزم من حجم تنظيم الدوله بشكل كبير وخاصه
ايضا اذا ابتعدت الحكومه عن الطائفيه فهذه
خطوات
ايضا يجب ان تتخذ
بالموازاة ضخامه الثمال الانساني الذي دفع
في معركه المس حتى الان وسبل وقف نزف
الدماء نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم مجددا الكتور الكبيسي قبل المرور
الى البعد الانساني في هذه المعركه هناك
كلام على لسان ضيفي الادمرال فالون يتحدث
عن اللبوس الطائفي لهذه المعركه اي تطييف
معركه الموصل الى اي حد باعتقادك
يعني منح التنظيم
وربما مساحه اكبر لكي يتحرك ويعيد بناء
نفسه
الان لا التطييب مرتبط بالنظام السياسي
يعني نحن دائما كنا نقول انه مقاربه تنظيم
الدوله داعش على انه اشكال امني هذا خطا
استراتيجي تنظيم داعش او ظاهره تنظيم داعش
هي هي منتج سياسي هي نتاج سياسي للعمليه
السيا السياسيه الطائفيه التي انتجت في
العراق بعد عام 2003 ولطبيعة
لهذه المناطق هناك عمليات تغيير ديموغرافي
واسعه النطاق بغطاء حكومي هناك محاوله
للهيمنه هناك محاوله لفرض الامر الواقع
ميليشيا الحشد الشعبي اصبحت يعني عنصر
اساسي في فرض الامر الواقع في هذه المناطق
وبالتالي الاشكال الاساسي في العراق هو
اشكال سياسي وما لم يعالج هذا الاشكال
السياسي اي حديث عن هزيمه التطرف هذا كلام
عبثي ولا معنى له لكن عندما نتحدث عن
الطييف نعم النظام الس سياسي في العراق
بمجمله نظام قائم على اسس طائفيه وهو يعني
يمد تنظيمات المتطرفه مثل تنظيمات داعش ب
يعني اسباب بقائها طيب طيب اي الادميرال
فلون صيحه فزاعه الان يعني لا تطلق الان
هي بدا اطلقها منذ فتره الحقيقه من ان ت
يتحول القتال الجاري الى ما سمي باسوا
كارثه على المدنيين ما الذي برايك ادى
ويؤدي الى هذه التكلفه البشريه العاليه في
في معركه الموصل وهو ما لم يكن مخططا لها
الى حد
كبير بدايه اود ان اقول بانني اتفق تماما
مع الدكتور الكبيسي بضروره
وهناك بضروره يجب التعاطي مع الوضع
السياسي في العراق ويجب ان تكون هناك
مقاربه سياسيه بالتوازي مع المقاربه
الامنيه والعسكريه نعم سؤالكم حول الوضع
الانساني الوضع الانساني صعب جدا خاصه في
هذه المدينه الكبيره ذات الكثافه السكانيه
العاليه واعلم ان القوات العراقيه وقوات
التحالف وايضا حلفائهم الاكراد يتوخون كل
شروط الحيطه والحذر من اجل تجنيب المدنيين
ولاه هذه الحرب وهذه مهمه صعبه جدا بالنظر
الى تواجد الاف من النازحين واللاجئين
ولكن القاده العسكريين على الميدان
يحاولون توجيه كل هذه القوات من اجل تلافي
خسائر مدنيه نعلم الان ان منظمه الامم
المتحده دخلت على الخط وهناك تواجد
لمجموعه من من الوكالات الدوليه الانسانيه
التي تقدم الاغاثه
وتقدم الغذاء والدواء والماوى بالنسبه
للنازحين وايضا للاجئين الذين فروا من
ويلات الحرب والقتال هناك في الموصل حتى
يتمكن الناس من العوده الى نوع من الحياه
الطبيعيه ان صح التعبير الان استمرت الحرب
واستمر القتال اكثر من سته اشهر وهذه فتره
طويله بالنسبه المدنيين دكتور قبيسي هل
كانت المعركه تحتاج الى هذا الثمن الغالي
الى هذه التكلفه البشريه الغاليه في ارواح
المدنيين هذا هذه الاعداد الهائله في في
النازحين والمشردين يعني ما الذي كان
بامكان القياده العسكريه العراقيه تجنبه
ولم
تفعل لا انا اعتقد يعني ال اللوم الاكبر
يقع على الدوله العراقيه وليس على
العسكريين العراقيين يعني عندما يعني لا
تخصص الدوله العراقيه وانا اتحدث هنا عن
مجلس الوزراء ومجلس النواب اموال كافيه
لاغاثه النازحين يعني كل ما خصص في موازنه
عام 2017 لا يزيد عن مليار دولار لمواجهه
يعني كارثه نزوح تتجاوز 3 مليون نسمه يعني
وبالتالي لا اللوم الاكبر يقع على الدوله
العراقيه اعطيك مثال يعني قبيل انطلاق
العمليات العسكريه جميع المنظمات الدوليه
والوزاره الهجره والمهجرين تتحد حثت عن
انه الطاقه الاستيعابيه للمخيمات لا تزيد
عن 150 شخص في حين كان هناك يعني توقع
بنزوح ما بين 800 الى مليون شخص وبالتالي
لم تكن هناك استعدادات كافيه اصلا ولا
تخصيصات ماليه كافيه اصلا لمواجهه هذه
الازمه الامر الثاني المهم انه يعني
المدنيين تعرضوا لحصار طويل طوال يعني
الفتره التي سبقت المعركه وبالتالي كان
هناك نقص كبير في امدادات الغذاء والدواء
ايضا كانت سببا مضافا لطبيعه الازمه
الانسانيه الموجوده العامل الاخر المهم
هنا هو طبيعه الاستراتيجيه العسكريه التي
استخدمت يعني الكثافه كثافه النار المفرطه
التي استخدمت في معركه الم الموصل منعت
الكثير من المدنيين من الخروج خوفا من ان
يكونوا يعني وسط تقاطع نيران بين القوات
العسكريه العراقيه وبين تنظيم داعش لهذا
فضلوا البقاء في بيوت ولكن الاستخدام
المفرط ل القذائف بمختلف الانواع ادت الى
ما ادت اليه يعني نحن هنا نتحدث عن تدمير
لما ما بين 60 الى 70% من المدينه وهذا
ثمن باهض
جدا اشكرك جزيل الشكر الدكتور يحيى
الكويسي مستشار المركز العراقي للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه من عمان اشكر الادميرال
ويليام فالون القائد السابق للقياده
الوسطى الامريك
والاسطول الخامس الامريكي من
واشنطن نهايه هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد دمتم بخير والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه